qu'elles soient chefs d'entreprise ou
porteuses de projets les entrepreneurs
yvelinoise rencontre généralement les
mêmes problématiques identifiées
mobiliser les ressources pour réussir
c'était le thème de cette 6e édition des
rencontres créactive cette année l'idée
c'était de parler des ressources donc
toutes les ressources qui peuvent nous
aider en tant qu'entrepreneur à se
développer donc les ressources
personnelles que l'on peut avoir pour
chacun d'entre eux mieux les ressources
matérielles la marque par exemple la
valorisation de l'entreprise les
ressources matériel informatique les
logiciels aussi les financements sans
des ressources est important pour cette
journée créactive ateliers tables on
était organisée dans les locaux de promo
paul la pépinière d'entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines comment recruter
efficacement faut-il externaliser
certaines ses tâches des questions des
réponses qui ont trouvé un écho
favorable auprès des participantes donc
moi j'ai lancé mon entreprise je suis
tout seul donc on a toujours besoin
effectivement d'échangés de 2 vous de
partager des idées avec les hôtes c'est
une très bonne initiative ça permet à la
fois de faire connaître ses produits de
pouvoir donner du conseil d'être à la
rencontre de ses clients en direct et
puis c'est extrêmement convivial c'est
une ambiance très agréable donc
c'est une très bonne initiative et 96
femmes sont membres de l'association
créée actifs fondée en 2004 tous les
mois des rendez vous ouverts à tous sont
organisées par la structure